JAMES WATTERS:
What's happening now
is that software is starting
to take on its own life
and building completely
new kinds of processes that
never existed in paper before.
And those are what's really
differentiating businesses.
And so the lifecycle of those,
and the change rate of those,
changes as fast as
people can consume them.
And this is a big change, from
a once-a-year deployment to we
have enterprises doing
20 deployments a week.
And so that clock speed
change and that style
of process change that's
happening is really remarkable.
So this is where you hear this
word digital transformation,
which I don't open
with, but that's
really what all of these
changes lead up to.
That change is, I think, at the
heart of sort of the Pivotal
and Google partnership,
which is we're really
bringing the ability to
go compete with software
and be great at
software, and do it
in a scalable,
data-integrated way to all
these large enterprises.
SAM RAMJI: We used to have
scarce, giant resources,
like mainframes, and the few
heroes who could use them.
But now we've got an
abundance of computation.
It's basically free.
Now, from 1992 to 2012,
the cost of computation
dropped by a factor of 3,700.
The cost of storage dropped
by a factor of 18,900.
So you think about the
absolute, all-out abundance
of computational infrastructure.
Well then, you've
got a new scarcity.
The scarcity is actually
the developers, not
the infrastructure.
So what they want, what they
want to deploy, the things
they can imagine, actually
have a much bigger impact
on your business than the
cost of the infrastructure.
We focused on
developer productivity
from another point
of view, which
is, how can you build
billion-user experiences that
can rapidly iterate based
on what users want, and not
also burden those developers
with understanding scale
and reliability?
So we've taken our
internal competencies,
which we call technical
infrastructure-- it's
the opposite of IT.
Get it?
It's TI.
About 11,000 engineers
who do nothing but support
the other 40,000 engineers who
support Gmail, search, ads,
right?
We have seven different
businesses that
have over a billion users each.
So that partnership is
actually how Google runs.
It's all about
developer productivity
for our developers.
The partnership with
Pivotal is about bringing
the best of what we know about
what that infrastructure is
to the best of
what Pivotal knows,
which is what are the runtime
platforms and the tooling,
like Spring, that
developers really love,
because it just gets
out of their way
and they get things done.
If your software practice
is not incredibly agile,
your business process
is stuck in concrete,
and you wont evolve.
It's very satisfying to
sit here a year later
and say Kubernetes and Cloud
Foundry are coming together
very pragmatically,
in some obvious ways,
but also some surprising
and very beautiful ways.
The de-risking of
open source helps
you reduce migration cost.
You can bet on Kubernetes,
you can bet on Cloud Foundry,
and know that there are vibrant
multi-vendor communities.
Everybody is worried about
making the wrong choice.
So how are they
de-risking their decisions
so that they can
make a decision now?
And everybody is worried
about developer productivity.
We've got a shared
infrastructure, the shared
management layer in BOSH.
We've got a shared
service broker,
so you can get to all
of the same services
like data services or analytics
services, machine learning
services, whatever you
want, wherever you are.
So just make it work.
So that joint engineering,
customer obsession, and this
focus on eliminating this risk
of this or that by making it an
and is a really big deal.
And if you watch where
the puck is going,
there's a lot more coming.
The truth is, value's
only found in the market
by customer interaction.
What you start with
is always wrong,
and then you have
to incrementally
get it less wrong.
So its all about cycle
time and velocity.
If I can iterate
my product based
on customer feedback
in one week,
and somebody else
takes a month, then I
can get 52 cycles in a
year, and they only get 12.
My software will be so much
smarter because its compounding
interest.
So that's what I mean when I
say you have to bet on velocity.
So when you look at
the Pivotal sprints,
when you look at the
two-week release cycles
that you get in Cloud Foundry,
when you look at the 9,000,
10,000 times that we release
software per day in Google,
like, we're companies
who've been practicing
velocity for a long time.
I authentically believe we've
got a great opportunity,
and there's no two
better companies
to go and do this for the
world than Pivotal and Google.